okay so the documentary people came today
if you were on live
you were like there when they like
literally knocked on the door and they let them in
and they spent a few hours with me just doing like
talking to me
talking about stuff like that we could talk about since my kids weren't around
and I showed them like old pictures and stuff
and then they actually came with me to exchange when I went to pick up my kids
and they filmed like what that's like
and in France there's like laws and shit where they can't show kids faces
like they don't need permission
because they're not ever gonna show my kids in the fucking documentary
so they're filming all kinds of shit but they're not gonna really put my kids
like their faces on anything
um
and yeah and then they came home and filmed a little bit
and it was really cute cause they talked to my kids and they were like
are you so proud of your mommy
she is so famous and proud of your mommy
so that was like really cute cause my kids were kinda like
oh shit Mommy's like
not like lying
Mommy really does do shit when we're not here
like yeah guys um
I'm sorry I'm hearing noises in my house
and then um
they're gonna come back tomorrow to film some more
and they're gonna interview me
and having a friend
I have a friend
that is an attorney
and they wanna interview her as well cause they wanna um
talk to her about like what the family court system is like in America
like what is it like to go through a divorce like this
what is it like to try to leave a traditional life so
so tomorrow more filming and stuff um
so yeah it was really exciting
really fun thank you
seriously to all of my friends on here
I love all of you that encourage me and keep me going
and I am genuinely trying to like
scream from the rooftops to help people
you know not fall into the same mistakes
not make the same traps
and help women to just feel empowered to be happy and shit
so hate on me all you want to
literally just trying to be happy and help other people be happy
but what else
you know anyway
I'll go live again tomorrow and hang out again and stuff
so yeah stay tuned
and as soon as I know about like
when the documentaries it'll be posted on YouTube
um obviously I'll post the link and stuff so